right so like facts number two number
two you're waving around what you wait I
don't know I'm just making peace a peace
listen this piece okay so I'm gonna open
up on the last episode I mentioned that
I will be talking about sleep cycle and
that is gonna be my first one today so
sleep cycle is an app that used for
tracking sleep you set an alarm last
thing at night and it presumes that
that's the final thing that you do so it
calls that your sleep you're going to
bed time it then tracks when you wake up
on a morning set an alarm off you can
give it a window of time between an hour
and 10 minutes during which it uses the
motion sensor and your phone to detect
your muscle sensor or the microphone to
detect the depth of sleep the airing and
it tribes to find a time to wake you
when you are closest to light sleep that
feature for me I don't use an awful lot
but I know it can be pretty effective
the thing that I like the most is just
tracking the amount of time that I've
been asleep I've used it for 1,200 plus
nights now so I've been doing it since
2008 the collection there yeah so your
correlates will be will be very accurate
nice well it wouldn't be are you still
using it
not recently right okay so in explain
what the car let's are I suppose well
yeah so the amount of data that it
tracks to do with your sleep is
unbelievable so via associate to the
weather the air temperature the pressure
the moon's position hmm the location
that geographic location that you're in
based on your phone's location services
it literally uses everything and then
plots it against how good was your sleep
so it uses the length of time that
you're asleep plus the depth of sleep
determined by either the microphone or
the motion sensor and then works out a
quality of sleep that's based on a
percentage that percentage then gets
applied against all the other bits and
pieces and then it shows you an average
of your time over the last week of a
month over
and it also tells you people in your
country what their average is so on and
so forth so if you're a bit of a the
sort of person who likes to drill down
the data on that sort of thing you can
really get into it and even if you don't
it tells you how long you've been asleep
and what the effects on your sleeper so
I know that when it's a non full moon
whatever the opposite is like
non-existent moon what is it
presently nor like no lower than that
path moon no blowing horn mean [ __ ] me
[ __ ] me knowing when there's no me my
sleep goes up by two percent believe me
no mo that's twice in the same month and
we think we've had two of them this yet
so we had one since blue live but that's
not phrase what is if we moon blue moon
is when we won that one full moon occurs
during the same month but this year it
was a red moon and and the super moon so
it was a blue blood red super moon that
was the final one with a lunar knowledge
is incredible I like the moon bought my
mama moon food what diamonds what my
business partners kid and moon for his
first birthday I'm eight no no I'm still
going coming
David's just having a little moon shrimp
through so I mean David do you like the
moon yeah good so sleep cycle see cycle
it you can get free version it's an app
your phone available on Android and on
iphone if anyone follows me on Instagram
it's a screenshot of it all the time
because I no doubt on it it's really
really useful and I recommend that you
try last episode we talked about meal
prep this is the man that got me into
that the slow cooker currently practice
meals earlier and he's reaping the
benefits not what a nice to you there so
it seems like a big fan of as well do
you know just a quick point in it you
know so like all I would look at in the
page hours really I kind of take with a
pinch of salt the whole
that'd be great I the the whole light
lunar cycle compared to asleep I agree
nice to have but it's a bit like you
know being told the world's going to end
that was not much you can do with the
information is that my anything that you
do look at or is anything you've changed
or like added stopped a solid routine in
terms of in terms of the native options
on sleep cycle no however you cannot
sleep notes I mean in terms of your
sleep routine yeah I'm going to add
these sleep knots it so sleep nuts are
more conditional options that you can
choose before you go to bed so for
instance you could have a sleep note
which says had caffeine after 6:00 p.m.
today spend more than five hours at work
work the night had alcohol didn't have
alcohol felt stressed did meditate
didn't meditate did went to the gym did
whatever and the choral up between
bunches of those mean that you can
perform an experiment on yourself with
any variable that you want so for me I
know if I have caffeine after 4 p.m. in
the day I'll have 5% were sleep does it
then lock that as something you can
enter again yes across time the study
just building your own day or on your
own sweet place if it is so I've used
that as well and it kind of tells you
like caffeine worsened asleep melatonin
increases you improved you speak like
things you think things it expects is
there anything that's unexpected they
came out of it for me yes but I think my
sample size was too small and what was
the unexpected thing said I'm a reduced
sleep quality little bit and that's
quite a common concern yeah common
complaint was oh my I can't remember the
other ones but they it changed over time
so I was like probably it's not the
affected melatonin house if I have three
milligrams of melatonin a five milligram
thing that's the strongest thing for me
unbelievable and 10% to thing improved
sleep I was having that you will never
reduce you sleep requirement by an hour
you will become dependent
after a little oil yeah but right okay
scope so another sleep one and now it's
time for you to set aside the ones that
gives us forgiveness and allow things
easy to be easy the body take care of
the rest
if we didn't ever know develop that if
pieces it's a like guy with a delightful
soothing voice and some soundscapes to
lolly went to sleep and there's
something really Pavlovian about it that
when you start to hear the voice you do
just get knocked out
so I sorry but just the end and it plays
again when you wake up but gently brings
you back up so it's Cabul it's a very
similar sleep cycle but sleep sucked
like a literary sleep cycle kind of it
doesn't track anything so if you maybe
if you if you're gonna use pieces and
you want trucking data as well you'll
probably need a Fitbit or a bit you
could easily use both could sleep cycle
doesn't wish you much better fit yeah
bit fit just directed what's your I can
enjoy but but can you imagine how hard
you'd have to google search engine
optimized to get bit fit above Fitbit if
there's anyone that can do face up face
but but but I developed a negative
relationship with it I've realized this
diseases yeah so I had it it was
initially something recommended by a guy
called Dave Asprey when I used to listen
to his stuff back when I was Bob down
Tino and I used to listen to it when I
would struggle to sleep so the noise the
voice is associated with me is with
nerving in asleep that's it that's
reverse conditioned them hmm classical
but wrong yeah I wasn't written that
first one I'd kill I mean honestly I can
now like a line I can't fall asleep when
something's up really
music audiobook or TV I can't force I
think for me I like for my falling
asleep to not be the focus of what's
going on it's not that I like this you
know if I'm if I'm like oh my [ __ ]
god I need it for it's like if you
listen you're hunting a small woodland
animal and you if you look directly
after its gonna run away see gorgeous
yeah you think that's I'm thinking far
too easily stimulated probably an excuse
to Johnny oh my god I didn't talk let me
think let me think
ah thanks my uses just turned a list of
over 30 okay it's probably more than
thing so again I'm very theme based
rather than specific apps but you have
got Hobbit bull written on that
something will have it both which is not
for building momentum with habits
something that for me has been the only
thing that allows me to do or build and
yet bend it build any kind of habit or
break any kind of habit is direct
one-on-one accountability some kind of
challenge with someone else and it's
something that I originally heard from
Tim Ferriss there's apps and websites
where you can give an amount of money
- it's like held in escrow and then if
you fail to do the thing or you hit in
the table fail to like continue with a
habit or fail to break the habit you
lose the money that you're creating loss
aversion to that thing and so having
some kind of competition or looking bad
in front of someone having that
accountability for me has allowed me to
be consistent with meditation journaling
sleep um it's like all the asleep
because closes up you do that by having
a Google Drive document where it really
makes multiple people have access it's a
spreadsheet that Elstad online yep both
people have access you log whether or
not you did the thing that you said you
were going to do and can see whether the
other person did as well - its exact
external accountability is a big thing
huge huge and obviously that's the
service we provide but it's some youssef
a night for those people listening but
yeah I think that because I've tried so
many habit apps yeah like this coach
taught me all lift puppet bull
there's loads of level of my way of life
reductant I think I've got at least
three and I've never used because they
make sure you get the habit of
downloading it yeah this is going to be
the thing that that you know changes and
I've got it now like how it's not gonna
be a problem I've got this new thing or
even like people who talk about
incrementally adding in habits and
things like that yeah it's something
that a meditation is something that we
all do the thing two things got me
meditating one was performers you surf
challenging me and then the other was
being involved in a challenge yeah of
daily like if the back of your head
someone else is meditating someone else
is gonna do that thing today
yeah I'm not going to be the one that
gives up I'm knocking you on the brakes
the show yeah and having it just
generally on like these these these ups
and that the process of building habit
as being like start with two minutes a
day build it up a three minutes a day
formula today tried that you got to like
three weeks in you're doing six minutes
a day of meditations on the site or
something in consequentially is still
below the tipping point of actually
feeling any kind of benefit yeah and I
was harping on about this to yourself
one day one a course in Liverpool that
he just goes just meditate for 30
minutes a day for 10 days and tell me
honestly they don't feel anything I'm
like fine Mike but that's what's
required for me to get lazy
see I told you son I told you an
attention isn't anything then that's
what did it that's what broke a seal
yeah right really interesting there's
two things there if like the negative
feedback from pieces causing you to
sleep worse because you only listen to
it on the days when you slept
Britany weren't able to sleep and the
negative feedback of meditating for six
minutes a day and been thinking like
well this is a waste of time and
actually like if anything doing that
makes you meditate less I'm
- first one is getting things that will
play on your mind out of the way early
in the day so for me if I don't meditate
before I leave the house it will stress
me throughout the rest of you lay that I
know I still need to meditate mm-hmm and
I'm like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't get it
done so what I've done is I've
programmed in that I can have I'm
allowed to have in my own mind a three
minute this is our headspace which is
going to be my next one a three minute
emergency session which is like you have
three minutes getting a car before
yourself you have three minutes just
drive a bit faster like so and that
three minutes at least means that I
still need to come back and try and do a
15 minute 20 minute a half an hour later
on by like right the anxiety of the fact
that I didn't do my morning my morning
thing that I said I was going to do mmm
that's out again another rhyme irony the
not meditating makes you more anxious
than if you just didn't meditate as a
person yep but yeah a little bit if you
build a very very high wall that you
then throw yourself off the top so yeah
next one's gonna be headspace I guess
when I first heard about was probably
what 18 months ago and it seems to have
just got everywhere since then and II
put it come the guy that owns it it just
released a podcast it's massive they're
working with Nike now there's a night
pack like he's working with huge NBA
teams like these these teams so the best
in the country in America at basketball
all sorts of stuff just been on a couple
of famous podcasts as well he's again
everywhere at the moment he was with
Russell Brand the other day I saw it was
Justin Russell Brand's podcast he's
fantastic
it's anyway headspace it's an app for
guided meditation if you haven't ever
done meditation before you will hear a
speak about it a fair bit and you might
just think it's all a bit whoo I've got
some friends who know it isn't for them
John Wallace owner of Reebok CrossFit
outside for him meditation is not for
him and I actually completely agree
based on what I know about his
personality and I do genuinely think
that there's a lot of people a large
minority of people should I say for whom
meditation isn't correct
however I do think it could benefit an
awful lot of people but the same
said in the last episode when we were
talking about people who want to get
into mobility but don't know where to
start you need to find the training
wheels version you don't go into a gym
and try and pick up 200 kilos off the
floor immediately in a deadlift when you
don't even know how it perform an empty
bar deadlift you're going and you do the
basics first and you get coach guided
meditation is an easy way to start off
that journey you sit down you press a
button on the app and you listen to what
they say exactly the same way as you
would do with the rawad that we spoke
about last time that you go through the
poses these are mental poses or mental
states that asks you to go through
thought experiments and over time as you
move through different packs you are
given less a fewer and fewer cues and
you allow yourself to be more in control
of your brain rather than the impetus
coming from outside it it tracks stuff
like daily streaks there's loads and
loads of different packs there's ones
for anxiety small performance creativity
at work family relationships all manner
of different things and you can choose
between three minute and that 3 minute
and 20 minute sessions for the most part
for me I've moved through different
guided meditation courses or the one I
keep coming back to the most has been
headspace and I think the length of the
sessions is good the fact that there's
so many and they're all different with a
little bit of different introduction is
really good and I like the
visualizations that he uses a lot of the
ones I genuinely do feel so he does some
about warm once so I'm filling up the
body there's a lot of check-ins with the
body as well which is nice yes it's it's
definitely definitely one of my favorite
resources and it's free again as well
you can get free trial so you can see
whether or not you like it
meditation ups what's your two things
just on what you said I think having
thing you mentioned about having a
backup of the meditation to fall back on
something else that I do with the with
the habits TRUCKING is hot wok every
habit I do as a scaled version because I
think having being able to maintain I
think the psychology of breaking your
streak with something yep
it's really negative again negative
thing like because you've skipped a day
you're less likely to do it again the
next day
is that how got that wave of you get the
catastrophic thinking right yeah well I
think my face again I'll finish the
packing exactly whereas if you meditate
for five days in a row you're more and
more likely to hit the sixth day seventh
day yeah
seventeenth day yeah meditating I think
I also started of headspace did the zip
1010 take ten yeah it is a great
introduction I think I've since moved
away from it I fraught from what I did I
don't I can't speak of what it's like
now when I was doing it I feel like he
made a big deal about you know it's day
three you feeling anything yeah yeah
yeah I feel that it was like you've done
100 minutes of meditation by then
detective take ten you know that's
enough to change your brain and things
like that and I remember thinking I must
be doing it wrong because I don't feel
any changes I think it vastly a lot of
the apps calms the same soft ride and
some of the Karma subscriptions they've
asked the underplay the time it takes
the investment it takes to actually get
to the point where you're like okay I'm
really great I can feel some change from
meditation so that's what I said I see
why they're doing that like if they just
delivered this negative like guys bubble
valve you don't know me I don't never
know if you don't have an hour to sit
down you can just [ __ ] like unless
unless you've got at least 200 hours
like what's the point you know obviously
that's not going to get people to
subscribe I don't buy in no it needs to
be inclusive I guess is what so another
one
Aubrey Marcus has done a fantastic guy
that owns on it he's done a fantastic
course called release into now and I
think we've all done have you donuts
come you haven't done the full but
you've done a bit to that is is the
meanings if you've done yeah if you've
done a if you've got yourself into
meditation and you've realized that it's
for you or if you're looking for a new
guided meditation I strongly recommend
that you buy release into now probably
the nicest most complete meditation
course that I've ever done like that's
not speaking from a massive pool both
options and it's in high enough doses as
well as
two minute session or an hour session
over there that's what makes you stand
out I think yeah yeah you can't mess a
balcony there's no ass graces ya know so
very much agree with both of you that
headspace is a great intro to meditation
if you have decided the Dennis you are
somebody who would respond well to it
just to quickly touch on that you
mentioned not everyone is a large
minority laughs AG you mentioned that
before as well yeah what's the how I'm
sorry I've never met meditated before
how might I begin don't don't decide
straight away some people are not for me
right and probably if they're deciding
early on it maybe probably yes that's
what I find so interesting young people
like Jordan you know how how do you
arrive at that yeah you've got to give
it a solid shot at 1500 hours before you
start and actually if you find it really
challenging and really unpleasant that's
probably a sign that you should bring it
again and if you if you're like well
actually are me I'm able to do it but I
I get more out of a physical practice or
with it then you may have a different
sticking point and we move through
different sticking points as we evolve
as not as if we have a static problem so
right now my sticking point is the body
it's not the mind but that's just
because I've now outweighed my physical
spiritual practices by I've outweighed
them with the amount of meditation that
I've done so which is a [ __ ] man how
much just to give cuz again so scale
like I I think I've I've slowly tiptoed
into this world the doors were opened my
[ __ ] me oh this is [ __ ] cuz I you know
you do a hundred minutes enjoying idea
I've done a hundred minutes how many
well this is now away just before I say
this okay I think the criticism that you
said of headspace is really important
that it does try to kind of push you
along and be like oh you know this is it
it's the ten minute abs Beauty blaster
Hamdi or the meditation absolutely 100%
and so as soon as you have to add the
intro to meditation from the guided
attention
now move away from guided sessions you
they can be they can be done as a crutch
a stabilizer yeah but really if you
start moving beyond it then you can
start to make some progress but I think
the analogy is that if someone's been
sedentary on the couch and not exercised
for four years Charlotte Crosby's at
home who you asked to work out the ten
minutes on DVD is not a bad start
yeah gets them off their feet yes and
then yeah and so there is a tendency
when someone's like oh I'm gonna start
meditating it's like okay I'm gonna get
a nap it's like the app isn't the thing
the practice is the thing so do whatever
is needed to establish it to be clear
all to get by it right yeah to get by
and get practice on it and I'd say we
read a book on meditation that there's
many very accessible ones by monks the
the best one that I found this is well
the most accessible one is mindfulness
in plain English by Hennepin look around
to know us like just because and as it
says on the tin it's like very clearly
written gets by in and teaches you the
method very clearly and doesn't give you
too much more to sittin ruminate to
think about as you can imagine a lot of
monks that are writing about meditation
can go mmm
d-ring them doing what we talked about
it's fairly esoteric because you haven't
realized you can't get that much and I
think it's better to save the esoteric
knowledge and wisdom for your own
experience because all of the stuff that
they talk about that is very esoteric
comes from the deep states that they've
achieved in meditation so you may as
well achieve them yourself rather than
read about them and then try and imagine
what might lie yeah yeah exactly
okay so let's do you still use an app
for meditations during that but the app
is completely minimal it's just a black
timer use at the time you say start will
stop
that's insight timer right insight timer
now I do use a little crutch which is a
the sound of a wooden clave every five
minutes just like okay gun stock at the
time so me I was gonna ask you was
someone who someone hears that I've done
ten in ten mm-hmm it's take time right
I'm not sure okay whatever whatever it
is you need to take both sides were in
the arms without a leg if you've ever
heard ugly protocol before you'll know
exactly what we do there's any sounds
side of the road cars game there's a
really small chance that you might be
listening to this
so you've done that you listen to Andy
say and you're trying to do it
unguided so I sit down for ten minutes
mm-hmm all I think about is emails
shopping Netflix there's stuff that
floods your mind and I go to the end of
the ten minutes well I have a long I'm
trying to do and it's annoying it's
frustrating like I've just sat there and
thought for ten minutes yeah
do you just persist with that or in that
instance is a guided session so I mean
to bring you back yeah I think if you're
really [ __ ] then you need you need
guided sessions which have the only
difference there is that you're still
applying the same method and I don't
think I think pick one method dig one
deep hole rather than lots of shallow
holes but the guided session will just
give you frequent prompts and as Chris
said the progressive overload element of
it is less and less frequent prompts
until you maybe have a prompt every 20
minutes or every half an hour or
whatever the back end of most of the
parks if you're doing a 30-day pack on
headspace the back end of most of them
will have Andy introduce you set you
down and then it will be probably about
every five minutes throughout the ones
who don't know yeah
you will never get to the point where
you sit down and you're like oh that was
incredible I was just I was so focused
for that entire time like the whole if
anything do start so for anyone who
doesn't follow us directly we I've just
come back from a 10-day meditation
retreat where did sort of 70 75 hours
during that during that time and the
predominant sense is you realize how
insane you are
you sit down they've got right okay
let's go follow the breath IV under my
nose
barely two breaths in you're thinking
about lentils or you think it yeah you
just say it makes me feel so much better
that that happens to you oh so much
enlightenment and so that the reps are
bringing it back to the object each time
and you do get longer and longer periods
but there's so many times where you
decide in a long session and you'll be
like twice like the last and the guy
says like that's okay like mmm that's
not yeah yeah don't judge your success
by I like the idea of Mentors I like the
idea of the little Gong every five
minutes because I'm not like it yeah
very subtle just like a clock tick or
something yeah right okay so we'll do a
quick a quick little loop around what
have you got it's like timer insight
timer oh do you want another loopner
that's for yeah yeah I'll go again you
know what muse news going deep in
meditation right so I got a message I
got a message of someone on Instagram
the other day after I uploaded a
screenshot from muse saying can you
please tell me about that app that
tracks your naps in the middle of the
day it looks really good because it's
got about a neutral and calm in it Oh
is he having an amputation having an
active nap what is that it's not just a
wait I'm not sure yet moving I mean what
amuse it is a little headband that you
wear on your forehead portable EEG yeah
it basically measures your brain
activity while you're meditating and it
translates the electrical signal that I
picked up into audio in the sound of
either like a busy park or a beach and
when you are calm for extended periods
of time it plays the noise of birds when
you are less calm they get the weather
picks up it gets more noisy and
basically you meditate through that
process and it then gives you a compa
centage it's actually really clever how
it work it gives you
school based on how many birds he had
how calm you were how many recoveries
you had so as soon as he sleeps I caught
it yeah yeah so for me I'm very numbers
driven yeah date orientated and I love
seeing I love being able to chart my
progress i quantify exactly you're a
power that you were power lifted that
this is life on percentages and RP as an
accountant yeah so yeah I'm yeah so when
I heard about it it's like 250 quid if
you me like free if you user I got the
18 film so I was sat in the car on the
way to work as an accountant at the time
and Paul Mort was the first person who
had ever heard and he was like I've got
this headband and when I do really well
I get birds and I was like right yeah
it's fantastic and I use it
I've used it I've done over a hundred
hours with it there's no verified birds
or when you have a sustained amount of
time with lo with lo brain activity or
calm you both start tweeting as the I
found the last aside I also got a
headband all three of us have gotten
johnny paid full price for his I got
mine brand-new but secondhand on eBay
and you see flash to get his for free by
shweta hero and Sweeney is an
interesting point who do you think's had
the most benefit out of the news
headband from the three of us of the
head but definitely not me after this is
Ron sang - I paid full price you know I
think most of it you've racked up so you
thought it reduces the cos here because
it was free use it right fine did you
use it once I see what you mean right
isn't it correlated to how much you
spend for it
what's the scale but I'm saying I like
benefit yellow benefit / price which is
infinite but yeah but in that place the
price is irrelevant if the price isn't a
factor in it there's no way it's
irrelevant that's it I see your point
but the total amount of benefit and so
if you if you have to if you quantify
benefit by saying I was used
rightful are you then I win yep I just
Camille just literally agreed the you
definitely did with Johnny posted a
spray
the other day which is it's fantastic
isn't it this morning which was how many
it was the his score basically comparing
a few weeks ago to now on Muse and it's
unequivocally better and it's amazing is
then if you are numbers driven in your
life I'm not fully sold on whether this
is just a waste of time with us it's all
one big prank it's again it's it's sit
and listen to my breath across my mind
yeah well you know our so easy to
podcast on this yep on the profane
podcast about your experience and I said
I raised you know what if isn't it all
just a load of who was said before give
it a hundred hours before you decide
it's a hundred hours you are never
getting back yeah if you get there
exactly in a load of bollocks so having
some way like as a you know anything
else you do like whether you if you were
saving money every month but you never
looked at you savings be pretty dreary
existence like you see if you trauma
lose weight that you never realize your
good example never measured your weight
and there's no way around it and this is
why you need buy-in because it really
now oh here 450 hours a my people said
you're pretty convinced unequivocally
you're asking if you're asking we come
back to stay and train here right
because you definitely feel better while
you are meditating because you have a
level of calm that you wouldn't have
when you're not meditating
I think getting a trait change which is
outside of the meditation is affecting
your day-to-day headspace for lack of a
better word that's a lot more difficult
to elicit I need a lot more difficult to
measure and interestingly I'm noticing
the trait change now but I'm less
interested in the state change whereas
earlier I was chasing the state change
yep just because it's really like it's
due for a penis if you want to find out
a little bit more about what we're
talking about here a couple of podcasts
that probably do you very well
sam harris nearly as various yeah this
is ham so with he was going to it ah to
goes to researchers in 111 i don't know
much about cast episode number hundred
and eleven of sam harris is waking up
podcast through the two membranes bulb
ask on I'm gonna love that would
actually be the word titties
[Laughter]
Audio mom Tigers peeking send all of
them popping peas right so let's do one
quick round result there's the quick
simple ones yeah
quick quick simple ones let me think
about a quick simple one
Hey I hope my quick some put one ready
for you guys need some time go on that
go sir I stole this from Chris Chris is
probably going to think of this one so
he'll be annoyed now but this was from
the founder of WordPress Noah whatever
no I told you Bertha's yeah what is it
look so you set your trackpad speed oh
this is such a good entry and then you
set your mates trackpad scroll to the
opposite one of those is correct and the
other one is not the other ones being
nasty
yeah good to me you know where some
people scroll the correct way way I
thought you're gonna explain the
trackpad we're doing it quick circle
scroll the incorrect way Minotaur
Youssef scrolls and then everyone else
uses the Apple standard settings and
Scrolls the right way right way so speed
up your trackpad incrementally say self
reminder now every month for the next
five months
speed up trackpad speed by one setting
if you do that in five months time
you'll be at the maximum setting that
you can get to so that's the [ __ ]
approach but the lot that was the [ __ ]
approach your approach was put it
directly to the fastest why it would
overshoot for the next three weeks as
you fly around the screen and control
computers having a panic attack
I think I'm just go Bulls in anger the
ones I couldn't have maybe you're like
peoples yeah okay well go out your fries
where if you track where they are put
them with a I'm what was like what was
the argument that within you you become
10 percent more efficient in every task
on your computer
it's hard to say whether that's happened
but it does feel yeah because when you
whatever even now you're limited by your
trackpad in a way that you can't
comprehend so I've got an analogy
everybody here has observed their mum
tried to Google something they move the
mouse down to Internet Explorer and
you're like ah it's like even Internet
Explorer and and they type
www.google.com type Google into the
Google search bar and then they'll move
the mouse up to the edge click sometimes
like yeah and then move them ask to that
little triangle at the very bottom right
press the down button yeah you're right
that's the best argument you've ever
given real free for a month accidentally
right Johnny Europe um this is it going
to be a very specific one to people who
film themselves training okay which is
might be a lot people might not be very
many people for a long time well so I
did power lifting and for a long time I
wasn't able to film my set while
listening to music so I even got went to
the extent of buying an iPod touch to
film my training so that I could
continue listening when you're doing
like a wander at Maxell another media
monster which is a an iPhone app lets
you video while listening to music
through the app which was like honestly
Game Change [ __ ] game changer for me
while I and I remember it so I saw it on
Bryce Lewis's Instagram story Bryce if
you're listening thank you for this but
I remember because he posted a question
saying like what camera should I buy
what camera should I buy to film my
training so I can listen to music at the
same time and someone was like matrices
media monster save them how long until
your music library in media mods know it
picks up Spotify unbelievable yeah our
game changer I thought you have to
jailbreak your phone no no no picks up
and you can even set it so that it's
there's a song that I play
all the time for a top set and it's just
whenever I press play media monster
that's a summer place that's also mmm
it really is that's really cool right to
media monster media monster I think my
last one is going to be my fitness pal
now I'm not going to go through
everything from my fitness passes you
can use it to track you calories your
color of caloric intake in also do it to
track water intake as well as even a
water bottle but if you are not will fit
better up what a logged water logged
is it that's a really really really good
name I'm gonna [ __ ] why didn't we think
of that along with the log lets you take
photos of the water and then photos of
their like the fluid you drinking such
as that kind of coke yeah and then you
should press that and it tops up a
little human to the amount you taught
your targets the for my photo full
version as in you take a photo lock the
quantity so that when you're logging you
just press the photo of the thing you
rather than like I've had eight cups so
that's like alidade my horse-pond at my
favorite start for logging your weight
if you are not prepared to spend 80
pounds on the winnings scale its fair
not think it's a no-brainer
spec policy you know you're never gonna
win that continue I haven't bought a
winning skirt for most of these things
we've all ended up in the same camp now
whose headband we're all using like some
form of sleep art so there's it we're
all evens that I see something that I
think is valuable and I go out and I pay
for the recommended retail price for it
youssef then acquires it in a snidey way
for free and then you get it through
some mate who works for the night
dissing up a discounted rate I'm not
that thing is a really representation of
everything that happens absolutely every
when you're over six-foot life is just a
little bit harder all of that benefit
you got of being able to call yourself
tall I have to bend down that a little
bit further
no but you everyone else is like told
you're tall aren't you nice and me and
Yusef kept called short us because we're
under six foot but it's okay because you
gets a free because we are not paying
our RP it's all of this
the failing is mine for not is it again
for being so why do you like solo well
precisely
well why this oh well I'm finally the
same reason why Youssef gets angry this
is - time travel again the reason you
have got angry the guys using Word
documents I'm that guy you are yeah
Youssef excellent goes absolutely not
there's gotta be a way around that and I
go well words on my laptop so I'm gonna
use word that's the price so I'm gonna
pay it
Youssef looks at it and thinks that's
not the price it's a proposal what I
might have to say yeah mmm thank you
very much thanks for your time I think
we see you life hacks 3 coming up soon
excellent
we've got so many more splendid many
more many many more hi
[Music]
you